[Applaudissements]
pour la guinée ça va commencer
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
on était bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je alors j'ai une beauté pourquoi après
que je te montrer ses seins parce que
john particularité sur le sourire du
voyage et sont dits chaque wii
collection l'indien de hong kong
l'autre assez de l'inde la grèce et
l'ecosse oui ils se ressemblent tous ah
oui parce que je défends toujours dans
la même chaîne d'hôtels complet un
regard ils sont magiques khatchik bacha
oui alors j'y reviens pas mais ce n'est
pas tout car si tu te trouves dans un
hôtel s'il veut étonner la femme de
chambre tu l'appelles et alors là je te
recommande cette chose là tu prends un
sainte ouine tu le place au dessus de
l'eau tu fais 1 2 et 3
[Musique]
alors tu ne peux pas rester comme ça
donc à ce moment-là essaye de le retirer
turp et non non
écoute je dis comprends rien du tout à
l'heure chaque une chaîne où il ya de la
chute de papier
alors tu ne peux quand même pas rester
comme ça donc si tu as vraiment trop de
problèmes je sais ce que tu fais tu
appelles le directeur études y regarder
au centre sont magiques et voilà et tu
retires oui mais regarde maintenant si
je veux envoyer son système alors la
jeune femme risque parce que si tu as
mal aux oreilles c'est toi qu'il
recrutera question de oui oui allez là
merci à ben non gérard peut nous
revenons enfin surtout s'attacher
monsieur cherchez pas pensé pas prix des
denrées rares
oui j'irai bien face aux poteaux
costumes des bâtons qu'est ce que c'est
qu'est ce que c'est que ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bacardi
oui beaucoup trop tôt possible
[Musique]
yu gi oh
la soirée dont poteau oui oui
[Musique]
brody
tous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tous
[Musique]
paris
aujourd'hui c'est un truc avec des
cartes à jouer
un truc oui chicala très facile d'accord
denis point une carte appartient
oui tu te souviendras bien pose là quand
ça te fait plaisir très bien et
maintenant pour retrouver cette carte
nous allons tenter quelque chose de très
simple on prend le jeu on le lance sur
la table et là il se coupe à une selle
cassée
le set de carreaux et là c'est ta carte
ah bah écoute alan clarke et bien il y a
un truc qui se résume à peu de choses
mais oui c'est du salon alors lancé
pascal jan cartes truqué un jeu vous
montrer comment la réalisons je suis
pressé important du gros sel
voilà et avec la colle ont fait quatre
petits points de colle sur une carte à
jouer
et sur chaque point de colle on place un
grain de gros ça attendez là vous ne
voyez pas très bien alors j'ai apporté
une grosse carte voilà son sens vous
rendez mieux contact voilà les grains
que vous voyez ici sont collés à quatre
points évidemment c'est une petite carte
ne se voit pas alors la façon de
procéder ensuite est très simple vous
placez la carte à jouer tout le jeu
comme ceux ci sur le jeu alors une carte
est choisi par exemple le 8 de trèfle on
coupe le jeu est en place la carte
choisie ici
maintenant on replace le reste du jeu
mais attention la carte qui se trouvent
ici est ainsi l'espace constitué par les
grains de sel va permettre le miracle en
lançant je pas tout à fait verticalement
main tout petit peu de travers regardez
ce qui se produit le jeu saute de temps
en temps il se retourne la moitié du jeu
the do ou alors ce sont seulement comme
ça ça dépend de la force avec lequel on
lance et alors là vous avez vraiment la
cape qui se trouve la v8 de trêve
nicolas toi quand tu fais temps en temps
je tourne un oui mais pour ça moi j'ai
ma botte secrète
ah bon en bas pendant alors je te laisse
faire je l'espérais
le secret c'est vraiment un trésor alors
il faut bien le pré cochées encore une
fois encore les autres j'ai une collègue
j'ai quelques petits ressorts magique et
j'en prends un que je pose d'un ressort
magique je le vois pas et je lui ai
demandé agnès deux premiers aux cartes
voilà j'étais maintenant je coupe le jeu
avec elle et je prends le petit sorte
qu'elles poussent sur ma carte et je
remets le récital dessus voilà
et maintenant je laisse le paquet et
cela aux différents vous avez qu à une
autre façon de faire ce tour mais alors
là avec un truc que je ne vous
expliquerai pas et de tenir le jeu comme
ceux ci est de demander à l'un d'entre
vous mieux et on va changer un petit peu
et elle regarde tu me le dis maintenant
une carte celle que tu veux tu regardes
bien mon jeu ciel car tu veux tu cap de
trêve alors regardez bien je fais un
petit mouvement sur le jeu et si je
lâche mon doigt regarde le jeu avance
tout seul et si je retourne n'ya pas de
cadre de trèfle ici mais là la première
carte est justement le cas de trèfle
bravo et l
ans
[Musique]
à
oh
ans
[Musique]
bon
où
oh
[Musique]
en
[Applaudissements]
oh
regard tech en avant et moment
[Musique]
les gens
les chiots
oui
oui et les bobos ah non les bonbons dans
la malle bien moi ça va finir pas si
vide oui on regarde
la coop ça non je vais voir
[Musique]
il n'y a rien dedans
elle est vide à lévis à bompas
[Musique]
allez tout madame
dites moi sont passés les bonbons elle
est volée ponctuée bon y'a pas toi la
patronne ce ne sont pas là demain
non non très bien
abracadabra
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
al'approche et toi
[Musique]